what's this this looks really are you
gonna throw it at me or something or do
we have to pour this on
oh that's the last the last dab we
internet the Apollo
let's begin
are we going in are we last diving it
and we call it the last dab because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last Wing you don't have to
if you don't want to and I'd actually
recommend you don't
I truly feel insane like I feel I feel
nuts
oh that's a good Shake
yeah so I bought a little present yeah
so I bought some maggots here here we go
that's not a dab how did you put on I
went a little crazy try not to do this
much but it's hard to dab oh how big of
a mistake is this huh hold on a second
let's talk about love all right that's
kidding
hey it's been a privilege but if we
don't come out the other end of this
experience it was all worth it it's been
an honor brother
shout out to smoking Ed
[Music]
one bite
two bites whoa I've including bone oh my
God are actually kind of saturated that
yeah come on man there we go Built For
This
should anyone thrown up from that uh
[Music]
every now and then there's like a little
pepper that gets swallowed it reminds
you yeah oh terrible idea
but it was yours uh-huh so I understand
but it's yours yeah I'll stand by magnet
line felt way worse like immediately
after the bite yep
but it's not as bad as you think there
you go
there you go we have scaled the heights
of spice Mountain if we've learned
anything along the way it's that you're
somebody who can do a little bit of
everything we really want to put the two
of us to the test what the [ __ ] else you
want so under these bizarre
circumstances I'm curious for your
perspective now we're about to get deep
yeah while I'm choking today can you
describe to me the vision of a Queen
Latifah sci-fi film
I'm alone on a planet
it goes down
I don't know if you remember this
amazing
for these
these
[Music]
for years I've watched this [ __ ] show
and I finally walked onto this set and
saw the sauces and saw your face I was
like
yes
bucket list bam
this has been my dream since I first
started YouTube was to one day come here
and I'm [ __ ] finishing the last week
okay what you do is as you bring your
arm up
turn your thumb a little bit
you give it an off-axis rotation so it
spins like this right
this works for me every time
I will never do this again this is a
mistake I don't know why people eat hot
sauce some questions science just can't
answer we saw the challenge we took it
on and we climbed to the summit of Mount
Scoville
incredible wow
that was pretty awesome
[Applause]